Buenos días Ángela en este momento
estamos en la sección en la región de
batoshinski donde fue el segundo ataque
esta mañana muy cerca a las 7 de la
mañana era el segundo ataque después de
ese que sucedió a las 5:51 bastante
fuerte y que realmente despertó a todos
los habitantes en especialmente a
quienes viven en estos dos grandes
sectores que fueron atacados aquí en
este momento vemos cómo llega esta grúa
a llevarse algunos de estos automóviles
que fueron impactados esta mañana aquí
alrededor de nosotros hay edificios que
están todos con dos ventanas quebradas y
la población y los habitantes están
tratando de reparar y de recoger los
daños esta mañana también decía el
alcalde de la ciudad que se había
cortado la calefacción en al menos parte
de ella y también el servicio de agua
mientras lograban repararlo pero este es
uno de los ataques más fuertes que ha
sucedido contra la capital las últimas
semanas especialmente desde que empezó
el año Así que aquí la población sigue
viniendo está viendo qué es lo que ha
sucedido y a este momento vuelven a
sonar las alarmas se dice que hay un
avión mix sobre el Orlando sobre
Bielorrusia que podría volver a amenazar
especialmente las regiones del centro y
del Oeste de Ucrania que fueron atacadas
como decía esta mañana pues Catalina
quisiera pedirle rápidamente que nos
ampliara un poco sobre la situación en
el resto del país
hay que tener mucho atención sobre el
número de misiles fueron 81 misiles que
fueron lanzados más ocho drones
camístasis ellos lograron interceptar 34
de esos misiles pero seis de ellos
especialmente y hipersónicos unos que
son bastantes casos dentro de Rusia
fueron lanzados también esta mañana que
dicen las autoridades rusas que era como
retaliación ataques algunas de estas
provincias rusas en las últimas semanas
hay cinco muertos en la población de la
vida esta ciudad que si bien ha sido
atacada se ha mantenido alejada de esta
guerra y donde hay decenas y decenas de
desplazados en los últimos meses desde
que comenzó la guerra también hay
ataques en la ciudad de Nitro y en otras
otras grandes ciudades del país donde
están atacadas las instalaciones
eléctricas y también residencias
especialmente también en la ciudad de
hark que fue atacada con insistencia 15
ataques sobre esta ciudad que ha sido
una de las más afectadas recordemos
durante todos estos meses de guerra